(classical music)
(brushing teeth)
- Why are you using my toothbrush?
- Oh I'm sorry.
I even notice.
- Are you gonna stop?
That's disgusting.
- We kiss.
It's like the same thing.
- No it's not.
- Yeah it is.
- Stop it.
- Stop it!
- That's not how I sound.
- That's not how I.
- Stop.
- Stop!
- Put my toothbrush down.
(giggling)
- Put my toothbrush down!
(laughter)
- Put my toothbrush down.
- Stop please.
Don't tickle me.
What the hell?
I'm not sorry that happened.
- C'mon.
- You can't just tickle people
to get whatever you want.
It's weird that I even have to say that.
(beep)
- 5.45.
- [Voiceover] You can't just tickle people
to get whatever you want.
It's weird that I even have to say that.
- No, no. (laughter)
- You're gonna give it?
- No, no, no. (laughter)
OK, OK!
Fine!
(police siren)
(techno music)
- Give me it!
Give it.
(laughter)
(yelling)
(techno music)
(machine clanging)
(buttons and beeps)
- Babe, you forgot your wal.
Oh my god.
What did?
- I got the toothbrush.
- Did you hurt someone?
- No, no.
I tickled people.
I went a little overboard.
I'll admit.
But c'mon.
- You gotta go.
- What?
- I'm not trying to go to jail.
This is weird.
- This is gonna be the
last time you see me.
- OK.
- You take that toothbrush
cause I don't need it.
- Great.
- Now you have two toothbrushes.
- It's a very weird
breakdown for you to have.
(techno music)
- You're not even Ivy League.
You have no experience or training
even remotely suited for this job.
I can say without a doubt
that you would never
and I mean never
work for my corporation.
Oh please. (laughter)
- Do I have it?
- Yes!
- Yes what?
- You you have the job.
- Yes you have the job!
You have the job.
You're hired!
- Alright.
- You don't take no for an answer, kid.
I like that.
(techno music)
(movie film rolling)
- Oh god.
- I really wanted to give you these
cause I miss you a lot.
- I don't.
- Everything sucks now.
- Dude you're a mess.
- I need to talk to my best friend.
- Ah.
Just.
Oh no c'mon.
OK.
This doesn't mean that we're.
Hey!
(yelling)
(laughter)
- You're under arrest for robbery,
grand theft auto, and assault!
- LAPD, bitch.
- What?
Jen!
Did you do this?
- Yes.
I told you I wasn't gonna go to jail.
(handcuffs tightening)
You're just a weird guy.
- Jen!
(yelling)
- Hey wait.
You guys still have my purse.
Hey.
(birds chirping)
(classical music)